I think most of us have seen games like
this.
It's turn five or so and a player is
getting ready to go to attacks.
Immediately a chorus erupts from the
would-be attacker's opponents.
Come on, man. I don't have anything.
Hey, don't attack me. I missed a land
drop.
Really? You're going to attack me? But I
guess I was just trying to be funny.
I like to call this style of table
engagement SBS, small bean syndrome.
When a player goes out of their way to
paint their deck as being in a bad spot
and deserving nothing but mercy.
Now, Commander's nature as a multiplayer
format means the table politics
naturally play a major role in a lot of
games.
In addition, a lot of people play EDH
specifically for a less cutthroat MTG
experience. Not everybody every table is
looking to win quickly or even win at
all.
I'm not a big fan of most forms of small
bean syndrome due to their tendency to
discourage attacks and artificially
lengthen games. But I can accept that
not everybody is trying to play the same
kind of EDH I am.
However, there are also people who share
my desire to play quicker and more
cutthroat games and who employ small
bean syndrome more tactically.
This may be intentional, but it also
might not be, which brings me to a major
reason for SBS's existence, deck
inconsistency.
If somebody has an inconsistent deck,
one with some powerful and/or explosive
cards, but a lack of support or
connective tissue for such cards, there
will naturally be moments of popping off
and moments of the opposite of popping
off.
This means that such a player can be
telling the truth when they say they're
having a whiff moment, but this can
still be a deception in some sense of
the word.
Let's try an exercise real quick. Here's
a graph of their deck's performance with
the Y axis being power and the X axis
being percentile of power at a given
moment. You know, 20% of the time
they'll be at least this level of
powerful. 80% of the time they'll be at
least this much lower quantity of
powerful. Make sense? No? Great. You
obviously got this moderately small
percentage of the time where their deck
is going absolutely ham, doing whatever
it is the powerful decks do, but also
this gulf back here where their deck is
farting around doing nothing.
Certainly, they're having a bad time
here. But this is often a situation
arising from deck-building choices. A
deck that dedicates too much space to
the synergistic and the explosive will
have some big turns and occasionally
massive wins, but also a lot of moments
where it withers to a single removal
spell or just can't quite put the pieces
of the puzzle together.
These moments could be made less
frequent by running more of that
connective tissue, more filtering, more
small-scale draw, and more creatures and
low-cost interaction spells to protect
themselves. If they're ramping to big
cards, they could run a larger
proportion of small-scale ramp spells in
their deck so that they successfully
ramp where they want to be more than 40%
of the time.
When a person is piloting a sort of
all-or-nothing deck, small bean syndrome
is a form of power level smoothing, a
way of papering over the power crater
they made for themselves and bolstering
these weakest moments.
And I don't mean this as an attack
necessarily. If this sounds like you,
please take this as deck-building
advice.
A related concept to small bean syndrome
is people who don't verbally talk down
their game state, but who do play in a
way that conceals how well they're
doing.
Now, at a CEDH table, this is the norm,
as it should be at that power.
You're trying to win a cutthroat game of
magic against other people trying to win
even more cutthroatly, and you have
every right to bluff, to downplay your
game state, and to otherwise engage in
low-level deception.
At a more middling power level, though,
this might not be the best way to go.
If you're playing a deck with a clear
win con, people might know what to
expect even if they're a bit scared
about it, but if you're playing a deck
whose wins result from weird tech pieces
interacting to create unexpected
avalanches of value and board state,
well, people might get a bit
apprehensive.
When a deck is doing a lot of things,
but it's unclear how it wins, people may
be asking themselves the question, "Oh
God, is it that? Or is it that?"
Additionally, there are some strategic
ways of playing that might involve
saving resources and trying to force
other people to use interaction first.
You might say to yourself, "Hmm, that
card is spooky, but if I block no
removal, somebody else might deal with
it, and then they'll have less removal
when I want to do something spooky
later."
My friend Mr. Hans calls this playing
like a nerd, and though it's decent for
a strategic standpoint, it's the kind of
slightly baddie play style that people
will eventually catch on to.
Whether or not you get punished for
playing shady or playing nerdy will
depend on the table, but you should keep
in mind that human beings have a natural
tendency to fear the unknown, even if
being unknown might feel like the
correct play.
For an example of a deck that performs
almost the opposite way, let's talk
about my Glissa deck. I talk about it a
lot, and I will do so again here.
The deck consists of ramp, draw spells,
removal, and big creatures. No bursty
wins, no surprises, and no weird tech
pieces or out of place synergy cards
hogging space.
There's nothing spicy with the commander
either. She just adds draw to improve
consistency and is a good blocker to
help with survivability.
The deck simply does its battle cruiser
thing. People who've played against the
deck know that's what it does, and if
people ask me what it does, well, that's
what I'll tell them.
If I'm currently behind while playing
that deck, well, guess what? When I get
back on my feet, you can expect more
ramp, draw, big creatures, and removal.
Get ready.
It's a very consistent deck. It's also
what I'll call a transparent deck. By
this I mean, you can always approximate
how well it's doing by looking at the
board state, cards in hand, and land
count of the deck.
If the deck has a big board, well, the
threat is right there. No extreme
synergies or combos to worry about
later.
If the deck has a lot of cards in hand,
there's a good chance it's packing a lot
of removal.
If the deck has a big land count, there
are all sorts of moderately scary things
need to worry about, but the odds of the
spookiest outcomes are lessened the
fewer cards in hand the deck has.
It's a powerful deck against a lot of
conventionally built mid-power decks. I
call it midrange crusher 5000 for a
reason,
but the transparency and absence of
sudden win cons means that people tend
to worry about it less than they
probably should.
Another transparent deck I have is my
Meria deck. Although that one has more
unique tech and response plays, it's
transparent because it's a Voltron deck.
The problem is right there on the board
in front of you.
If there's a Meria on board with a lot
of equipments, I'm doing pretty well.
Most of my draws will be exiles off the
top, so you're seeing most of the stuff
I'm seeing. The scary stuff is all
visible.
There might be some protection spells in
my hand, but the deck devotes a full 10%
of its space to protection, so that much
shouldn't be a shock.
Meria also has the advantage over Glissa
that is low to the ground. My deck can
create a value engine with its commander
to exile cards, but that value is more
small artifacts and creatures, and the
deck doesn't do much if the artifact
count is low or if the commander gets
removed. Even with a higher artifact
count, the deck still only hits one
player a turn and gains maybe four cards
worth of value.
My $25 Rakdos discard deck is even lower
to the ground, only incrementally
drawing cards with a handful of scrappy
creatures, and honestly, that's the
deck's only saving grace.
It deletes people's hands and makes them
upset, but the rest of the deck is just
grindy creatures and a commander to
clear the way for my small group of
two-twos and three-threes to attack.
People will sometimes attack it out of
spite for a bit, but the non-discard
portion of the deck is so utterly fair
magic that people will usually go, "Oh,
you're just doing that now."
Huh.
And won't worry about it too much.
All three of these decks pair well with
a style of table engagement I like to
call fight the table ideology. They can
happily admit to exactly what they plan
to do. They can do it fairly
consistently, and they are prepared for
the consequences if they become an
enemy.
Me and Mr. Hans originally coined this
phrase to describe the optimal play
style for mixed power level games, or
alternatively, games where one player
gets a decisive advantage early. If
you're playing more powerfully than
other people, you could play close to
the chest before popping off with a
power turn and deleting the table, but
that's not really fun for anybody.
However, give your opponents the
information they need to know and be
open about the general shape of what
your deck is doing, specifically how it
wins and what cards you're playing are
doing there, and suddenly you've got a
dynamic game where your opponents are
strategizing about how to keep you in
check while managing their own
individual plans.
Any deck can partake in this ideology in
a game playing against lower power
decks, and I encourage giving it a try.
But as a method, it also works as a more
general style of deck building and play.
Now, I can already hear some of you say,
"But Alex, why would I want to be the
enemy?
I don't want my life to all to be eaten
into the sun by a bunch of quivering
nerds who I've been smugly informing of
their impending demise at the hands of
my deck."
Well, first, if you are in the dominant
position, doing literally that can lead
to some really fun gameplay as long as
you're not an ass about it. But more
broadly, this method can actually save
your deck from some hate, and let's talk
about that.
This might seem odd for hate dodging,
but step one of fight the table ideology
is that you should pose some sort of
clear threat to the table with a good
degree of consistency.
This could be early damage, big mid-game
beats, board wipes, stacks, and so
forth.
This will mostly come down to building a
deck that's focused and isn't filled
with unnecessary tech pieces or
creatures out of sync with the game
plan, and you can accomplish this step
on a shockingly low budget.
The point of this step is that what
you're doing needs to be visible.
To go back to an earlier point, I've
seen hyper techy mid-range decks which
fill their board with unusual permanence
with no clear sense of how they'll be
used.
If you do this, people might feel a
looming sense of threat, but with no
obvious sense of what to worry about,
this might simply result in them
attacking you.
By contrast, if the threat is visible,
people can make their own educated
calculations, and that calculation might
just be "Eh, it's probably fine."
Similarly, consistency is important
because that will be baked into people's
calculations as well.
If we take the inconsistent explosive
deck I was talking about earlier and
average out the power, it might very
well be lower than a deck engaging in
fight the table ideology. But people
aren't going to be thinking about
averages. They're going to be thinking
about the fact that you swung at them
for 90 on turn five last game. That's a
lot scarier than a deck that
consistently swings for 15.
Step two of fight the table ideology is
to be open about the threat that your
deck poses to the table.
This doesn't mean you need to overhype
yourself or give people constant updates
on your draws, but be straightforward
with people.
Verbally, this could mean saying, "Yeah,
my deck generates a lot of artifact
tokens, which I can use to accomplish
various effects. I don't have very many
right now, so I'll need to get a lot
more and have an outlet for them before
I can do anything too scary."
In terms of play, being open can just
mean having a thing you're clearly
doing. Don't let your opponents imagine
what you're doing with all of these
fishy plays. Have a goal and execute
clear steps along the way.
One easy example for this is hardcore
ramp decks, which work well because
everybody knows they're scary at a lot
of mana, but there's no singular land
drop that signals the deck being a
problem.
It evokes more of a gentle gradient of
concern from your opponents rather than
the black and white concern of a random
spooky permanent. And this can lead to
the deck flying under the radar. This is
doubly true if you're not running a
singular win card like Torment of
Hailfire, but rather a win involving
multiple cards used in a complex way,
since decks can kind of just blend
together in people's minds as, "Yeah,
the deck does big things when it gets a
lot of mana." Which is conceptually less
scary than a one-shot.
This sort of ramp deck is a great
example of transparency being
unexpectedly effective at avoiding
attacks compared to more opaque play
styles.
I've laid out the basic framework, but a
natural question that might arise is,
"Can my deck be played this way?"
I do my best to play decks that are
relatively consistent, so a lot of mine
do end up following this mold, but even
in my case, some decks will be trickier
to do this with than others.
Decks with combos are generally more
difficult to do this with as they're
naturally less transparent due to the
level of importance they place on cards
in hand, which is by definition a hidden
zone.
For this reason and others, sometimes a
deck isn't a great candidate for this
kind of transparency treatment. However,
I think that a good exercise for every
deck is thinking about what it would
have to do to become a good candidate
for this.
What happens if you remind your
opponents of the strongest win con in
your deck along with the conditions
required to get there right at the start
of every game?
What happens if your opponents treat
that win con you mentioned seriously?
If your deck is sometimes a slow
mid-range deck and other times an
explosive combo list, well, that might
be something to interrogate a bit more.
I have a couple of other things to say
about playing like a nerd and other
forms of pseudo politics, but I couldn't
find a nice place to fit them into this
video.
Instead, I posted them in a 3-minute
long unlisted video.
I've left the links to that video in my
description and it'll likely stay there
for a while, but eventually I'm going to
edit it out.
After that, you can find that video over
on my Patreon and there's a good chance
I'll post more end notes like that over
there along with occasional full-length
bonus videos.
Sign up at patreon.com/salubriousnail
for $3 a month if more content sounds up
your alley.